well it looks like some sneaky Democrats
are working behind the scenes to send
Joe Biden to the retirement home of his
choice according to a new report from
axios members of Joe's party are quietly
jockeying to succeed Biden in 2024 if
the big guy does in fact bow out some
are beefing up their political
organizations going to early
presidential primary States and
embarking on resume building foreign
trips probably explains why Gavin
Newsome was out in China and plowing
into children this was a charge heral
that was definitely not a block it was a
charge and it was embarrassing uh you
would think kamla is the shoe in to
replace Biden but check out this
headline from the messenger quote KL
Harris tries another reboot to win over
a skeptical public what is this like the
millionth reboot for KLA and just like
all the other attempts to remake her
image it ends once she gets in front of
a microphone one of the greatest threats
to democracy is Miss and disinformation
now the fact of Miss and disinformation
is not new but what increasingly has
happened with the evolution of
technology is Miss and
disinformation can spread quickly and
with AI in particular can take on a form
that makes it very difficult for the
receiver of that information to
distinguish between fact or
fiction I don't know what we just heard
I think it was about AI uh Harold I'm
going to ask you uh first here again uh
let me just get this straight Nome Rana
uh Corey Booker put into Fun together
reportedly for 2026 of course Dean
Phillips JB pritzer the list goes on and
on what are they doing here with
2024 I don't know I think that um anyone
that is seeking to undertake a quiet
campaign for the nomination of his or
her political party won't win uh the
best campaigns which are winning
campaigns are bold they're loud they're
engaging they're strategic they're
substantive um these kinds of things
happen happen on on both sides uh it
gets it gets a lot more tension uh
rightly so over the last one or two
cycles because we have third parties and
uh you're able to raise money
differently um but I don't suspect that
anyone will quietly beat Joe Biden
you're going to have to loudly beat the
incumbent uh in a part we've not had an
incumbent president defeated in a
primary they've been challenged and
those Challengers have I think weakened
them in the general um but I think
they're probably I'm not not naive about
this they they're probably believing
that if something if President Biden
decides not to run for some reason they
want to they want to be prepared and
that looks as if that's what they're
doing yeah and and Dana the option is
it's it's not simply bitting him in a
primary there is the outside option as
well of replacing him at the at the
convention which is messy because then
you have to figure out how to get them
on the ballot that's also very difficult
Dean Phillips is the Minnesota
Congressman challenging Biden he had his
first town hall a heck of a day
yesterday yeah that did not uh do well
his first uh Town Hall I encourage you
to read up a little bit about that that
seemed like a real doozy but I just
would like to imagine the Democratic
Governor's group chat like on text and
hey you go you go to New Hampshire I'm
GNA go to South Carolina you go to like
we got to figure out a way to do this
but they're also plotting against each
other so then like the subtext under the
text messages would probably be like a
fun thing to see I also think that the
White House uses these comma reboots as
a distraction for conservative media so
that you don't focus on the other things
like the Eon e omy or the Border or
crime even though voters are paying
attention to all those things
conservative media you like watch Comm
speech and you're like I I gotta comment
on that because what was she talking
about in terms of AI so I also would end
on this the Biden team says the
fundamentals of the race show we are
still in a strong position in my
experience if you are saying the
fundamentals of the race are strong you
are really worried about what's
happening Romney used to say that McCain
used to say that that they both lost
that's see and that's the that's the
entirety of the issue Greg I mean Joe
Biden will be pressured to leave the
race whether not it's a convention or
being beaten in a primary if it's seen
that he'll lose a general election and
right now I mean to the their point Dan
and that language is being used there's
certainly no strong thing he's going to
win a general election yeah it feels
like the plot of succession you know
with all the kids jockeying because the
dad has a heart problem they're all kind
of just sitting there waiting for the
right time they have to do it all at
once I think I'm going to use an analogy
uh using air travel to describe Joe's
presidency if you're on a short puddle
jumper of a flight you never really
settle in right you keep your jacket on
you don't grab a thick book CU it's
going to be over soon so don't get too
interested in the experience that's Joe
right you need a young president who's
going to be on that plane for a while
because then he makes sure that the
experience is livable this has been my
problem with Joe for the last 3 years
your problems he doesn't see as part of
your life he sees them as part of his
life and he's nearing the end of it he
doesn't sweat the small stuff right I'm
had a good life he he takes everything
in stride whether it's the Border
whether it's crime whether it's
inflation because all of those
consequences it's you know I'm not going
to be around for this we need a
president who actually is going to feel
the consequence of their policies we
need somebody young in there you know
Kay it's not just the names the list of
names I just read off to Harold there's
also RFK Jr out there and a No Labels
party potential putting a candidate
forward I mean there's a lot of things
in the way of Joe Biden winning a
general election and then oh yeah a
republican nominee yeah Everyone likes
to focus on Trump and the challenges in
the general but my goodness to your
point RFK Jr if he gets on enough
ballots in the right states that is a
deal breaker potentially look 6 % was
the amount of Voters who went third
party in 2016 that was when Hillary
Clinton ran it was 2% in 2020 and two to
one those voters broke for Joe Biden a
third party candidate could be his
undoing a lot of people argue it was
Hillary Clinton's on doing and then
enthusiasm 38% of people say we're
voting on Joe Biden because we like Joe
Biden 58% say we're voting on Joe Biden
because we hate Trump and then it flips
for Trump where it's nearly 60% saying
we're voting on Trump because we like
Trump Trump he has an enthusiasm problem
potentially a third party problem so for
all the talk about Trump look at Joe
Biden he's got a lot of troubles heading
into 2024 Nancy Pelosi said that no
labels represented a threat to our
democracy starts to sound like soda
Trump soda soda anything represents a
threat to our power is a threat to our
democracy hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else
El